Bộ giáo dục của thống cho biết đến ngày 1,5 bộ giáo dục vào đầu tạo đã dịch được báo cáo của bác bí tư trên bà bị tư gửi phương.
Chết cơn sở giáo suất mạng lưỡi trường lấp, các địa phương đã xe dựng tương án sắp xế của họ bối được tự tế.
Theo tổng hợp của bộ giáo dục vào đầu tạo số cơ sở giáo dục công lập trên cả nước dự kiến giảm tự bà bị bà bị bà bị bà bị bà trăm tà bị sau,
xuống còn 2 binh in 2 tà bị tư. Tức đơn giảm mấy bà bị gên 1 chắc lình 2 đầu mối,
đặt tỷ lệ 1,5 bà bị bà bị bà.
Vìa sắp sẽ chùi ổ được thực hiện theo rứng tổ chức, trường nhiều cấp học,
chuyển cơn sở hiện có thành cất nhiều hoặc niệm trường.
Tông thời sắp sẽ lại các trục tâm giáo dục tình suyên,
chúc tâm giáo dục nghềm nghiệp, giáo dục tình suyên,
lối với phùng xấu, bùng xa, binh lối, binh dưới và hài đầu,
đã điểm trường cần thiết cơ bản vẫn được vĩ trì giám bà làm quyết học tập của học sinh.
Bột sấu dục ở đầu tạo sau biết mùi in trường học sau sắp sẽ phải bảo nảm một phát dân
một hệ thống của anh chỉ thống nhất, vấn công gió người của trách từng vân hiệu,
điểm trường, đông thời gian lý đồng mộ về giết sự tài chính tài sản giữ nhiều
mắn chú, lội chú, át hoàn thực bầm và không trái chữ trái.
K hiện các địa phương đáng khẩn xuân kẹt tòa 1 mộ mấy, bố chỉ nhân sự,
mắn sấu tài chính tài sản, khu sơ rữ nhiều và xây dựng kế hoạch giáo dục,
nè các khu sở giáo dục và thành gồn định, trước khi bức vận nắm học hay kiện khu trái miếng sấu,
hay kiện khu trái hay biểu.